[Music]
and change the system news oh they're
gonna say ching chang chong news you
know submitted by JK news is a daily
need in my life a mom emails or
daughter's school say she won't be doing
homework anymore
mom I'll be doing a daughter some work
anymore no the daughter won't be doing
homework anymore you know this mom main
Asian watch that she is no Asian parents
give their kids even more homework on
top of the homework that happened to me
you know my mom gave me all these like
math homers when I was younger and I
couldn't go out to play until I finished
them meantime that's not even a joke
this is real life people yawn yep yeah
so all of you guys out there doing extra
homework look JK they did extra homework
and look what I got done so don't get
mad I'll use that [ __ ] you know what
they used to do to me my grandson will
give me like 20 questions and every
question I did wrong it's an additional
three so those 20 questions because you
turn to God and play you're probably
going to miss at least like four of them
so now those twenty turns into 30 to
turn into 45 10 to 15 what about big
it's about and you find then you [ __ ]
get addicted to jacking off because you
can't go outside that's why I can take
you to Jack you know that's not my
collegues hooker stop pointing that gun
at conviction look at me yeah
you know what happened to me I've
protested because I rather get my ass
beat and to do homework you showed her I
was like I rather just take the beating
and then go outside
I wasn't defeated as a parent and like I
don't even have that option my mom would
say tired after this mom her name is
bunny one-way punches you mean everybody
yeah that's her name how do you spell
this man-on-man UN and I I thought it
was bah am i I'm a good man sanitary
sandwich she's a 33 year old mama she is
an American living in Quebec an author
and a blogger okay all right so she sent
this email to her school she posted on
her Facebook would you really cool yeah
hello my as teachers Maya will be
drastically reducing them none of whom
were she does this year she's been very
stressed and it's starting to have
physical symptoms such as chest pain and
waking up at 4:00 a.m. worrying about
her schoolwork load she's not behind
academically and very much enjoy school
he's consulted with the tutor and a
therapist suggested be lightened her
workload doing two to three hours of
homework after getting home at 4:30 is
leaving little time for to just be a
chav enjoy family time
and we'd like to avoid her sinking into
a depression over this thank you for
understanding
warmly muddly o 432 at 4:30 that's late
that is pretty late my school always got
out at 3:00 yeah I know because I would
remember watching the clock and just
waiting [ __ ] Oh sick three o'clock yes
Vanessa it may be a after-school
activity is Zillah because I mean like I
know these days a lot of kids you know
they have the regular school and then
they deal with their extracurricular
tutor stuff and they give him a little
bit later right oh like after school
program of some sort yeah so bunny she
post a bit fun with this caption pretty
lengthy so bear with me okay here we go
my kid is done with homework I just sent
an email to her school letting her know
she's all done
I had to drastically reduce but I was
trying to be polite because she's
finished my 10 year old loves learning
she independently
read 10 to 12 chapter books a year and
regularly researches topics that
interest her right now she's writing a
story about wolf
she takes coding classes loved painting
and like something called roblox that I
don't fully understand but over the past
4 years I've noticed her getting more
and more stress and it comes to school
and by stress I mean chest pains waking
up early dead bull in general she's in
school from 8:15 a.m. to 4 p.m. daily so
someone please explain to me why she
should have 2 to 3 hours of homework to
do every night how does homework until
6:30 then dinner then an hour to relax
or finish the homework before bed make
any sense at all it's family time not
important is time spent just being a
child relaxing at home not important or
should she become some kind of junior
workaholic at 10 years old to do know
that in Finland homework is banned and
that they have the highest rate of
college bound students in all of Europe
children do not need hours of homework
to succeed yet we act like sitting at a
kitchen table after a full day of school
somehow makes sense it does not it does
not it does not
children need downtime after school the
same way adults need downtime after work
they need to play with their siblings
they need to bond with their parents in
a relaxed atmosphere not one where
everyone is stressed about fractions
because surprised I am NOT a teacher
children need time to just enjoy their
childhoods or is that just for the
weekend although we do homework on
Sundays also my kid is all done with
homework if the school wants to punish
her for it then I guess I'll have to
figure out how to home-school I'm very
nervous about it because although I work
from home
I do work I also have a three-year-old
who only goes to preschool two mornings
a week any seven-year-old in sight
second grade I'll have to hire a tutor
to help me and we'll need to find a
group of parents doing the same thing
but I have no choices at this point we
all want our children to grow up and
succeed in the world while I believe in
education I don't believe in for one
second that academics should consume a
child's life I don't care if she goes to
Harvard one day I just want her to be
intelligent well-rounded kind inspired
charitable spiritual and have a balance
in her life I want her to be mentally
and emotionally healthy I want her to
know that work is not life it's part of
life work will not fulfill you it will
not keep you warm
we friends community giving back and
being a good person will do that I
suppose I'll hear from her school
tomorrow we have decisions to make but
going forward this is a homework free
helpful and I don't care who knows it my
kids my kid needs to be a kid
I feel so conflicted about this because
on one end that's a very very logical
argument and if your kid is learning
doing research on their own why can't
they relax them to get home but the
other side of me is like I grew up in a
homework age and I want people to suffer
the same way I did
now you don't yes I do you sit in that
chair all of a sudden you've had like
[ __ ] David thoughts no that's just
tell em I thought I grew up so [ __ ]
Asian with extra [ __ ] homework all
the time so my my uh even when I learn
piano I had my level one [ __ ] which
is the [ __ ] what the teacher assigns
me to do and my mom will go and find
other sheet music and at the end of the
piano that's been which is way far
advanced for my capability school can
you also teach him this so one side on
playlet in business days Go marchin
and then at the end of it I'm like
stretching my fingers out cuz I'm
[ __ ] trying to cover notes that my
little hands can't even cover on the
keyboard I get extra long for everything
should I learn to play stupid oh you
work for me when you don't want to do
the work anymore no I didn't play with
it you just like your parents think that
you're not very capable and they won't
expect much out of you secrets secrets
of a batch I'm smart I was just stupid I
had the option wasn't smart enough I
don't figure that I I always tried my
best and it got to the point where my
teachers were calling my mom and saying
that I needed special school and I was
like yes
you know how Asian moms always give me
[ __ ] math homework right even though
after you finish your [ __ ] they want you
to do extra [ __ ] so I remember I was
only doing addition subtraction whatever
and then she's trying to get me to
memorize the multiplication table and
I'm like but this ain't even my time yet
to do that and I got a [ __ ] date at
4:00 that we're supposed to be going on
a bike ride to like the park and I'm
like what am I going to do to get out of
this right so we had a standoff like it
was straight up like I don't know what
I'm doing I don't know I can't do this
mom and then she's like yes you do just
do it this way and I'm trying my best to
pretend that I [ __ ] don't understand
what's going on and it works and then I
kind of got it and then this part is a
blur this is her telling me I was so
young I don't remember it but she goes
okay I'm going to cook you your favorite
like dish it's like this fish with
[ __ ] um you know soy sauce and stuff
and I'm like oh my god you're gonna
[ __ ] cook me that and she like yeah
but you got to get this done first oh
okay
she [ __ ] got me I think I know how to
do it now and she says halfway during
her meal she just came back and she saw
me playing with my toys and she's like
how the [ __ ] did you do this perfectly
bobbing you remember that so a little
troll but yeah that's that's the way to
do it guys just lie and pretend and
pretend that just make sure your parents
realize that you're kind of on the level
of Forrest Gump and you'll never go to
Harvard destroy their dreams become so
stupid so she gets to Leroy their dreams
best advice don't you guys feel guilty
about that though like because like for
me when I was younger I felt like an
obligation I don't a--first to my
parents values to myself or to someone
right to do my homework and to actually
try I was just trying not to get beep no
I never really felt like that because I
always had my own agenda and if whatever
they wanted on me didn't fit my agenda
then it just i was not inspired to do it
i think for me it was like if i wanted
to do something else but my parents had
like two different agenda for me I would
just feel guilty and then I would change
my agenda and then do what they wanted I
did it Beecher asked Michael if you
didn't do what they said
no they'd never be my that's why it's
the difference what the hell I mentally
guilt her too or mentally [ __ ] them over
like there's this one time where me -
friend we wrote Mike we wrote a bike
store on the neighborhood right and I
guess they went a little bit too far
than my parents wanted so they're like
when I got home I told them and I was
old underway to go to this one but I
went further no no I thought somebody
rode bikes you know around this justice
distance right and then I'm they're like
oh that's a little bit farther than we
want you to go so next time don't go
that far right so the next day my friend
I we're going to ride bikes again and
when we got to that point I was like oh
I feel kind of guilty you so I just
turned around in my home while my friend
was like why why why he just went up all
by itself I'm not a good kid
you're also not a good friend yeah I was
a great friend also a really really good
friend
what the [ __ ] Michael why are you
leaving me the funny thing about this is
that um my parents would have never even
known if I had gone farther you know
then they wanted but I still feel guilty
then turning around your best friend
horrible friend was a good friend you
can can also when I told all my friends
that yes they wanted to get kicked out
of their house they could stay at mine
yeah that's a good friend so I was
always harboring people that were
getting kicked out of the house all the
time in high school well there was a lot
of response to this post and for one
example it says as a fourth grade
teacher I fully support this in fact I
have not given my students the first
night of homework this year and their
academic growth has been just as much or
more as it seems from other classes in
the past not to mention the fact that
they've seemed less stressed and ready
to learn when they walk into my country
at home another one's it's like a child
psychologist saying thank you for being
brave and taking the stance and standing
up for what you know to be the right
choice for your daughter you're modeling
so many positive values that go beyond
academics here there's no focus on
family time keep it close in a hug
school response
I was curious on what happened with the
whole school situation but she never
posted an update how do you feel about
this as a money
well Isaac has I've gotten to that great
because next year he's going to be in
fourth grade and this girl's in fourth
grade and fourth grade is like where the
hard like were tomorrow so I'm preparing
for that this year but I mean yeah I
feel like kids should have time to spend
at home I think you should have homework
yeah I mean if you they can't get done
what like they're there the entire day
like she doesn't until we're like three
and you got to go back oh that's more
than a full-time job yeah exactly you
know why I hate homework I have to check
the [ __ ] work I mean Casey hated hard
so [ __ ] much competing realizing what
the [ __ ] we're not teachers we don't
know how to like teach it to hands I
keep that [ __ ] in the [ __ ] classroom
yes that's mine I don't expect the
teachers wipe my kids ask about their
diet at home but they might have to wipe
his ass from time to time
no I'm gonna I don't expect the teacher
to [ __ ] cook my kid barbecue at
school you do your school [ __ ] I do my
home [ __ ]
tag team boom yeah it should be like
that and like how she said like there's
there's a schools in Europe but they
don't have homework and they do just
fine it's not better it's just so
stressful for kids and I hated homework
and I'm not about to do it again
stop missing out on all of the JK news
uploads don't forget to subscribe so you
know when the videos are coming up and
for the last video click over here
[Music]